[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the state rests its case in the state of
wisconsin versus theodore edgeco but
will the defendant take the stand plus
the one-time attorney for stormy daniels
heads to federal court what charges
michael avenatti faces and new
information in the search for missing
girl harmony montgomery investigators
reveal the timeline leading up to her
disappearance but first opening
statements are presented in the federal
trial of three ex-minnesota officers
charged in the death of george floyd law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin opening statements began in the
federal trial of three former minnesota
police officers charging connection to
the death of george floyd prosecutors
say the ex-cops violated floyd's civil
rights and convicted ex-officer derrick
chauvin pressed his knee on floyd's neck
prosecutors say it was the duty of 36
year old two tao 38 year old thomas lane
and 28 year old jay alexander king to
step in at the time of floyd's death
floyd's killing in may 2020 sparked
national unrest after video of the
officers surrounding floyd went viral in
the video floyd can be heard screaming i
can't breathe prosecutors allege the
officers deprived floyd of his
constitutionally guaranteed rights by
not intervening or providing medical
assistance of the three lane is the only
defendant not charged with failure to
intervene presumably because he asked
chauvin multiple times to change floyd's
position in opening statements
prosecutors said the ex-cops made a
choice not to step in defense attorneys
countered saying floyd's death was a
tragedy but not a crime cameras are not
allowed inside the federal courtroom
where proceedings began on monday the
state trial for tao lane and king is now
scheduled for june shoving pled guilty
to violating floyd's civil rights in a
hearing last month he was already
serving a 22 and a half year sentence in
state prison for floyd's murder
joining us today is l.a county deputy
public defender phillip duvet and terry
austin phillip how do the federal
charges that these officers are facing
differ from the state charges
well the criminal charges carry up to
life in prison if this jury finds that
these officers failed to intervene in
preventing shoving from harming george
floyd
and ultimately resulting in his death
that could carry up to life in prison uh
the other serious violation is that they
had constitutionally under the eighth
amendment
uh a deliberate indifference to the
medical needs of george floyd
resulting in his death in other words
they cast a willfully blind eye towards
his needs now to be fair they did call
for medics and if i recall correctly
from the evidence it took an eternity
for medics to arrive now on the state
side
there is no need to prove a
constitutional violation you would have
to prove the underlying assault uh the
underlying battery
the underlying homicide or if a perjury
occurred
resulting in a death or incarceration of
an innocent person you could be
prosecuted substantively under state law
for those crimes but otherwise you would
only have a civil remedy ah so now terry
what do we understand the defenses to be
especially considering considering
chauvin pled guilty
well they're all going to say they
didn't violate any constitutional rights
of george floyd and they're going to say
that they were following orders and
police policy separately i think they're
going to say something different though
king is going to claim that he
absolutely did try to get a pulse and he
expressed concern about that lane is
going to say that he was just leaning on
the legs and he absolutely was trying to
get
floyd rode over and so he's going to say
that he's trying to save his life and he
did not violate any uh constitutional
and tao is going to say he was following
orders
yeah makes sense we'll see how it plays
out in federal court thank you both
switching now to tennessee for an update
on the so-called waffle house shooting
where jury selection is expected to
begin on tuesday on monday suspect
travis ranking appears in court for a
pretrial hearing officials say rinkin
opened fire at an anti-coach tennessee
waffle house in 2018. four people were
killed he was later arrested after a
34-hour manhunt rankin's trial was
delayed for months as he was treated for
schizophrenia he was eventually deemed
fit to stand trial on monday both sides
ironed out details for the coming jury
selection process which is expected to
last a week defense attorneys also noted
the defendant's mental health issues
will be addressed but not the issue of
competency
drawn our estimation number one
the defense has no issue with motion
number one
except to say unless the state were to
open the door
through any proof or questioning that
they present as the issues of competency
we would have no intention to try to get
into that subject matter all right
now when we say we're not trying to get
in that subject matter i take it you're
not
like you're going to present evidence as
to his mental state as
without getting into the issue of his
competency absolutely yeah i just want
to do it
yeah sure and that's what we understood
we've we've met with council any number
of times so
uh don't believe and there probably will
be some questions that would be asked of
the
experts of and what do you do for the
courts
so that part of
that but getting into the
into the
weeds about it the opinion that he was
actually incompetent for for a period of
time
no objection that he went to mtmhi and
all that kind of stuff and was treated
there and so on and so forth right i
just correct crystal clear where we are
statements are expected to begin next
monday ranking has pled not guilty to
all four counts of murder if convicted
he could face life in prison
and a former prominent south carolina
attorney is facing even more charges
related to alleged financial crimes alec
murdoch has been hit with new charges of
up to 23 new crimes murdoch allegedly
defrauded several clients out of
millions of dollars the new indictment
brings his number of charges to 71 in
total it includes 19 counts of breach of
trust with a fraudulent intent and six
counts of computer crimes the combined
total murdoch is accused of stealing is
more than 8.8 million dollars the
disgraced attorney is also facing other
charges for an alleged suicide insurance
fraud scheme murdoch allegedly hired a
man to kill him in order for his son to
collect an insurance payout this all
happened a few months after his wife and
other son were gunned down at their
family home that case remains unsolved
and murdoch has denied any
responsibility for their deaths
still ahead on law and crime daily the
third trial against one-time celebrity
attorney michael avenatti begins in
federal court but first the
disappearance of harmony montgomery why
investigators say information about
these vehicles could help in the search
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back the stepmother of a young
girl in new hampshire who's been missing
for more than two years appears in court
on new welfare fraud charges long crimes
and levy is here with that and new
information about when harmony
montgomery disappeared
investigators believe that they've
actually narrowed the time frame of when
harmony montgomery disappeared and we'll
have more on that in just a minute but
first the little girl's stepmother kayla
montgomery appeared in court and pleaded
not guilty to charges of theft by
deception and two other counts of
welfare fraud prosecutors say kayla
montgomery accepted food stamp benefits
for more than a year for harmony after
the little girl went missing court
documents state montgomery told police
her estranged husband adam told her he
took his daughter back to the little
girl's mother's home in massachusetts in
2019. harmony's father adam montgomery
is currently in jail charged with
hitting her in the face in 2019
adam's uncle told police that he was
physically abusive with the girl
meanwhile kayla montgomery has struggled
with addiction and wanted to be released
on bail she's been in jail for nearly
three weeks
i spoke with the program uh
one of the one of the directors there
i spoke to them about whether or not
if she was released on bail
could she go into the program
uh
she indicated it would be a better
situation
the judge said that kayla montgomery
could go to a drug treatment center
without posting that five thousand
dollar bill now back to that new
information about the timeline of
harmony's disappearance new hampshire's
attorney general says the investigation
has revealed that harmony disappeared
sometime between november 28 2019 and
december 10th of 2019. the ag says that
kayla and adam montgomery were living
out of cars similar to the ones that you
see here one a silver
or
silver chrysler sebring that is and
another was a blue audi now the attorney
general also says that kayla and adam
montgomery had their two children with
them after december 10 of 2019 but
harmony was not with the couple brian
thanks aunt jeanette let's bring back
l.a county deputy public defender
phillip dube and terry austin terry
caleb montgomery is charged with about
1500 worth of fraud but will the false
statements she made in filing for
welfare give us clues as to where
harmony is
i think it's going to be difficult to
calculate the exact date that she
disappeared but as angenette said the
new hampshire attorney general basically
calculated that her disappearance was
between november and december of 2019
and the prosecutors have said that the
stepmom was accepting benefits for about
18 months after her disappearance so
who knows what the exact date was but
what we do know is that crystal the real
mom had not seen her daughter since
easter of 2019
and we know that the manchester police
had not seen the daughter since october
2019. so i don't know if there's a tie
between the acceptance of the benefits
but we do know she's been missing for
quite some time now phil it's
heartbreaking to ask the question but i
still have to um
could this be a murder case against
kayla and adam even if we don't find
harmony
oh
absolutely uh it doesn't necessarily
have to rise to the level of murder but
they could file some type of homicide
charge uh be interesting to see what
kind of statements they have from the
parents you know about the last time
they saw the child the healthy child
whether or not any biological evidence
was ever found anywhere such as in the
car the trunk or the last known
property where the kid hung out
i'd also like to see what was purchased
with all that money that they collected
from the government you know do you see
any items such as diapers children's
toys you know gerber's baby food stuff
like that to show that there is a child
in their orbit but absolutely
circumstantially it is not hard to prove
a homicide absolutely now anjanette how
important could the cars that adam and
caleb montgomery had in 2019 be to the
investigation
well brian they could be everything or
they could be nothing they could hold
evidence uh philip kind of alluded to
that just now uh could be physical
evidence pertaining to harmony and what
happened to her or maybe there's nothing
in these cars at all but the new
hampshire attorney general's office
really wants people to look at these
vehicles
and maybe it will trigger some type of
memory where somebody saw something also
we should note that the ag's office says
that those vehicles were in much worse
shape those are of course just
similar photos but the vehicles they had
at the time were in much poorer
condition all right thank you all for
the update coming up on law and crime
daily the state rests its case in
wisconsin versus theodore edgeco how the
defense begins its case
plus a third trial begins on monday for
one time famed attorney michael avenatti
what charges he's facing in federal
court
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
sarah palin was supposed to be in
federal court monday for her defamation
trial against the new york times but
it's now been delayed after the former
alaska governor tested positive for
copenhagen
palin filed a libel suit against the
newspaper and a former editorial page
editor for allegedly defaming her in a
2017 story that linked a 2011 arizona
mass shooting to her political
activities the former vice presidential
nominee alleges the article said her
political advertisement took aim at a
victim of the shooting on arizona
representative at the time the times
says the article was changed within a
day and that the error was an honest
mistake palin has a an uphill battle
improving actual malice from the
editorial page editor or the times
that standard from the alleged
defamation of public officials was set
58 years ago by the supreme court
a case called new york times verse
sullivan the trial is set to restart
with jury selection on february 3rd as
long as palin is asymptomatic
also in political news the third federal
trial begins with opening statements
against fallen celebrity attorney
michael avenatti avenatti rose to fame
while representing adult film actress
stormy daniels whose real name is
stephanie clifford who accused former
presidential president donald trump of
providing her with hush money payments
to quiet the news of their affair
daniels fought to throw out that deal
which later sparked michael cohen's
prosecution for campaign finance
violations and fraud avenatti now faces
charges for stealing 300 000
out of an advance for daniel's memoir
prosecutors say he falsified a document
to receive the funds an indictment says
he used to pay money to he used to pay
the money to his law firm employees and
for personal expenses like making a
luxury car payment in 2020 avenatti was
convicted of trying to extort millions
of dollars from nike he also faces a
retrial in california where other
clients claim he stole from them
back to break down an attorney's fall
from grace is l.a county deputy public
defender phillip duvet and co-host terry
austin terry how did enoti get here from
being a high profile lawyer to having
these multiple cases
you know it's a slippery slope when we
start taking funds from the clients and
the american bar association says you
cannot co-mingle these funds hold them
together you have to maintain separate
accounts so he obviously got sloppy
about it you know he's already been
convicted from that nike case and he is
appealing that case but frankly his
license has been suspended and
regardless of the outcome of this case
his legal career is pretty much over
yeah now philip how do prosecutors
usually attack embezzlement cases and so
how do you think they'll end up doing
that just here in the avenatti case
they're going to show that avenatti used
stormy daniels money like it was an atm
machine they're going to have to show
that he committed what we call
aggravated identity theft meaning using
her name her identity her personality
such as date of birth
social security number and possibly
falsified her signature
and uh you know fraudulently wired the
funds to himself and if convicted this
carries 22 years and i'm telling you
brian terry and anjanet if you're
listening that money is long gone
i would believe that as well but like
they say follow the money and that's
where we get the answers we'll see how
it plays out when we come back the
wisconsin road rage trial who defense
attorney is called to the stand after
the state rested its case all that's
still ahead on long crime daily
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily we
head now to wisconsin as the state rests
its case in the theodore edgecombe
murder trial and defense witness
testimony begins edgecombe faced his
first degree intentional homicide in the
shooting death of jason clearman it
happened in september of 2020 when the
two got into an altercation on the road
prosecutors say edgecone was on a
bicycle when he punched clearman through
the passenger side window clearman's
wife evangelina was driving at the time
video shows as edgecombe rode off the
couple followed him onto a bridge
clearman gets out of the car and
approaches edgecombe that's when edge
goldman shot him he allegedly fled the
state and was arrested six months later
in kentucky edgecombe was claiming
self-defense
after the prosecution arrested monday
the defense motioned for the first
degree intentional homicide charge to be
dismissed
with the evidence that's been submitted
is the video and some of the testimony
about one gunshot
in our view that's just simply not
enough to indicate
an intent to kill
so we're asking this the
court to dismiss at this time
the defendant shoots a firearm into the
victim's face at close range intent to
kill can mean either intent to kill or
the individual
it's practically certain would cause the
death
when you have a gun
and you point it at someone's face
and you put a round into their brain
it is practically certain to cause their
death
the testimony is that
the defendant as the state noted
uh at least allegedly pulled out a
handgun and shot
mr clairman in a very close range
the testimony was two or three feet
maybe closer maybe a bit further away
and he put a bullet literally between
his eyes and in his brain
that is
enough to proceed
the defense motions denied
several officers and an eyewitness
testified for the defense monday
afternoon mr edgecombe is expected to
testify on his own behalf monday morning
the judge told the jury he has plans on
wednesday and would like to wrap up the
trial on tuesday
all eyes are on edgecomb possibly
testifying so let's jump into that
philip what testimony does edgecomb need
to present to the jury to have a chance
of being acquitted based on self-defense
well in order to get the self-defense
jury instruction the first thing he's
going to have to show is that he did not
provoke this by all accounts he
sucker-punched mr clareman you know he's
going to have to have a darn good reason
for hitting a passenger that had he hit
mrs clearman as the driver of the car i
might understand okay and it might give
the jury pause uh as to what she could
or did do with that car to harm mr
edgecombe but he needs to answer why he
felt the need to use deadly force as
opposed to reasonable force as to mr
clear but because he was clearly unarmed
coming uh briskly toward him on foot
with nothing in his hand and that he was
on the lamb for six months and that he
lied about his identity when he was
finally apprehended in kentucky so he
has a lot of questions to answer to get
that jury instruction of self-defense
now terry where do you think edgecombe
was going to struggle the most on
cross-examination in trying to say this
was all self-defense
well i think the issues that philip just
raised were perfect i think he's going
to struggle on most of those issues that
initial punch is going to be hard to
defend the fact that he was the first
one to quote unquote draw blood so
that's going to be very difficult and he
was carrying an illegal handgun so that
can't help and frankly the you know shot
at the close range is definitely going
to hurt all right well thank you for
joining us here on long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you